[Music]
i just have a question about my sneaky
snakey 12 year old
she takes my clothes she takes my makeup
including my eyebrow gel so i'm gonna
i'm gonna put a hard no on that one you
gotta draw the line somewhere sarah and
that's it
[Music]
he's the one that calls i can feel good
he's the one that makes you feel alright
i love that song hey it's the doctor
john delonay's show
they should drop in an octave he's the
one they call that that sounds creepier
if you sing it like that johnny cash
johnny cash does dr feelgood would be
the record of all time that'd be amazing
quick all right um hey for those of you
listening welcome to the show so glad
you're here mental health show wellness
relationships we talk about everything
schools education all of it
um hey james kelly
do you guys
insider baseball do you all trim your
eyebrows
no
no i uh
everyone's small if i have to but rarely
all right i've got a large forest
growing atop my eyes right so i i do
every once in a while when i'm getting
like at a barber i was in new york a few
weeks ago and i asked the guy
um or no he said trim your eyebrows and
i was like sure and i was just walking
down
down on the streets and i saw a
barbershop and i thought this feels like
a new york thing to do
not a great idea but i did
and as he started trimming them i
literally started laughing like he took
so much off i can run faster but now
they're growing directly forward like
they're growing
not this way they're pointing at you
my friends
i can let you borrow some of my eyebrow
gel
you're officially on friendship
probation effective immediately kelly
is that a thing
yes
i love america guys we're gonna be okay
as a country and a society we're gonna
be okay if we've developed eyebrow jail
we're gonna be all right and on that
let's go to sarah in canoxville in
knoxville tennessee what's up sarah
hey how are you dr john good hey do you
have um
eyebrow gel
i do yeah
dude i'm learning so much this is
fantastic
i feel like everything in my life is
different i should listen to this
podcast and learn more things okay so
what's up how are you
i'm good i i just have a question about
my sneaky sneaky 12 year old
i
you have the only sneaky 12 year old in
the whole world i know i know so this is
going to be you know a really difficult
question but um she's our oldest she is
12 she is um just sneaking everything
so my question is
do i need to be searching her room and
by everything i mean
she found an old ipad and was using it
to get on the internet unsupervised she
takes my clothes she takes my makeup
including my eyebrow gel so i'm gonna
i'm gonna put a hard no on that one you
gotta draw the line somewhere sarah and
that's it right
boundaries um
so i'll answer your question we'll get
to it
where where does she learn sneaky
you know my husband and i say she was
born sneaky she was sneaky as a toddler
um
and i i am not sure you know i try to be
very open about talking about
these are our expectations these are our
boundaries
um
and so i don't know if it's just being a
12 year old now that she's
being sneakier
or if she just doesn't feel comfortable
talking to us about stuff and and would
rather sneak around
so yeah so what
this is a whole other conversation we
could have at another time you're in
knoxville come down we'll get coffee
here in the in the studios and we can
chit-chat about it
um
whenever somebody's got a really sneaky
kid
i always want to step back and look at
are there conversations in the house
like hey don't tell your mom
or we're gonna go get sonic drink do not
tell your dad and we kind of laugh and
play
is there somehow is this leeching its
way through the rocks and making it to
the uh aquifer down below inside of her
maybe not um but i always want to look
at where am i quote unquote being sneaky
anytime somebody walks in the room do i
um turn my phone off real fast or are we
watching things on tv and then she walks
in all sudden we hit me are we creating
a world where she wants to know what's
going on behind that curtain right
um
so
that that's one one thing the second
thing and you touched on and i think
it's really important is is there a
world that she inhabits where she is
told these are my boundaries versus
here's the way our family is
um this is the way like you better do
this
let me say it this way
often kids who feel like they are
responsible for the emotional regulation
of the adults in their lives create
inner worlds that nobody else has access
to
and then adults call that sneaky does
that make sense
yeah i think so it may not be your house
that may not be your world that may be a
teacher that may be a coach it may may
not be any of that stuff right it could
have like you said just she got shot out
of the can in that way i always want to
look at what is it about this ecosystem
that my
son or daughter doesn't feel safe
talking to me about like what what is
why would they need to go down that
rabbit hole and hide or whatever
so that leads us to
um
your your question and this is gonna be
a controversial answer and i don't care
um
they do not have a room they are 12.
yeah okay
particularly when it comes to
electronics
search every electronic let them know
you're searching every electronic and
hold them accountable as this is who we
are as our family when it comes to
electronics
that might mean that you are going to
change what movies you watch that might
mean you're going to change some of the
music you play because this is who we
all are
and but we are definitely going to get
involved in those things what i don't
like kids doing is imagining that
they have some sort of inner sanctum
inside their parents home that no one
else has access to
uh that's how you end up in some major
issues where parents are like i had no
idea they were building a bomb i had no
idea they had this or that or they had
drugs and
and i always want to say it's like
literally 25 feet from your bedroom how
did you not go in there it's like well
that was their space like no dude
they're 12 they're 10. there's a reason
it's against the law for them
they can't get their own home right
because they're kids and this is a very
modern phenomenon
i also know there's a ton of pressure so
tell me if you just said hey i'm gonna
start checking your room or she caught
you going through her stuff
what would that even like would that
cause a fight
no i don't think so because i i've told
her you know hey i found this in your
room i think i'm probably gonna start
checking your room and not telling you
you know and and she just kind of said
oh okay you know it really i was
expecting more of a reaction out of her
but she didn't so i'm almost wondering
if she
feels safer with me checking in on that
um there's some of that probably um i
don't want it to
room checks are about
let me see it this way there's not like
a um like they're going to stand outside
like in a in a salute position and
you're going to go through the room like
with the white glo that's not we're
talking about it's more of i'm going to
be in and out of your room all of the
time
uh you are gonna help me change your
sheets
you are i'm gonna check and make sure
your room's picked up
um once every couple of weeks we're
gonna go through and make sure your
drawers make sure your socks are all
folded up right it's not a matter of i'm
gonna go in because i don't trust you
you don't want to do that you don't want
to set up a culture where you are
untrustworthy so i'm going to go through
all of your things
there is a culture i'm in and out of
your room it's not weird right it's it's
it's actually weird in my house when my
son's like dude you haven't come in my
room in a few days
because
i'm in and out of there all the time and
so when i'm in and out of their autumn i
can point and say dude pick that up
gross or clean out your snake cage or
whatever the thing is does that make
sense
yeah and he knows i'm going to be
helping him change his sheets which
means as a dad i've got to get off the
couch and actually help him change the
sheets
but he also knows if he hides stuff
under the bed i'm going to find it
yeah you see what i'm saying
yeah absolutely so it's more of a
cultural shift inside of a home it's
less of a
what i don't want people to do is hear
this and hang up and then go okay cool
great like raid time like that's man
that you're going to create a great
division between you and your child it's
more about i want to be more and more a
part of your world
um have you taken her out and just
started like a routine
mom and daughter breakfast have y'all
started that
no we haven't i would recommend that
more about house middle school and if
you can start being honest with her
about some of the crap you had to deal
with in middle school
there'll be some connectivity there and
what we're doing there is building a
well of
that old lady that lives in this house
she's trustworthy i can trust her you
know what i mean
yeah and then you can get to the deeper
conversations of like tell me about tick
tock what's so great about it like why
is this cool why is it not cool right
and then you can really get into some of
those conversations that they can only
have when they feel safe but thank you
for loving your daughter enough
oh yeah she's great
she's wonderful she's so smart and
athletic and like she's she's just the
best yeah that's so cool she's lucky to
have you um and you touched on something
i think it's important before we before
i get off the phone here
um 12 year olds are super curious and i
don't ever get upset with curiosity i
love it i think it's great
if i have pro have provided access to
things in my home
usually via the internet because
of um because i lack boundaries or i
wasn't paying attention i don't ever
blame a 12 year old for their curiosity
i blame myself for not creating
boundaries that are going to keep my
kids safe
the same as i don't get upset with it
well i would definitely get upset but
if a 12 year old has access to a loaded
weapon that's on the adult in the room
not the 12 year old right and we can
make all the rules like 12 year olds you
don't do this and great the adults have
to step up there right so um
yeah i think they're gonna be curious
it's gonna be both and when's when
there's a behavior with a kid always
remember this i've said this a bunch
i'll keep saying it behavior is a
language behavior is a language what are
they telling you kids sneaky they're
telling you
i have to have a safe inner world
because my outer world isn't safe and
let's work on that that level of safety
somehow somewhere
she's lucky to have you sarah we'll be
right back
[Music]
you all know there are lots of things
that make me nuts but one thing makes me
more nuts than anything else
buying a home and my friends who
refinance their homes they tell me it
makes them nuts too
i love living in a new home but i gotta
be honest
i'm no good at buying one and that's why
i'm so thankful for people like my
friends at churchill mortgage churchill
is a ramsey trusted provider who we've
been sending people to for over 20 years
to help with home mortgages why
because they're committed to doing
what's right for you and that means
walking you through paperwork that's way
over your head that means making sure
you get the right mortgage that you can
pay off as soon as possible and they'll
try to upsell you a bunch of nonsense
that's going to hurt you down the road
and most importantly when you're making
this big life change you can actually
breathe because you've got an expert in
a team who have your back listen if
you're about to buy a home and make a
big change
save yourself the headache and call
churchill mortgage today at triple eight
loan 200. trust me that's triple eight
loan 200.
this is a paid advertisement in mls id
1591 nmls consumeraccess.org equal
housing lender 1749 mallory lane suite
100 brentwood tennessee 37027 programs
are for select loan types only and are
not available in all states or locations
all right we're back um hey
there's a guy named trevor who works on
this show and he creates the thumbnails
for youtube and cuts and pastes and i
don't understand all of whatever does
he's really smart and talented
but the other day he was putting up the
thumbnail and the title and it said
extreme mental health what was it james
it was extreme mental health facing
extreme mental health and relationship
challenges except he had a typo
trevor had a typo and it said facing
extreme metal health
so great so great
and with this summer's big tour poison
motley crew and def leppard doing a
stadium tour
we're all gonna get in our walkers and
get our dentures in and we're gonna go
rock kelly's already she i saw the
pair of jeans that you cut super short
for your soup bringing daisy dukes back
everybody it's gonna be
ugh i can't wait it's gonna be so fun
but the tickets they're a little bit
proud a little bit proud of the tickets
yeah they were over 350 dollars per
click guys we're not seeing gas prices
let's back that thing down a little bit
let's take about 35 50 65 off that's
cool all right let's go to morgan and
tyler tx
what's up morgan
hi dr john how are you
um i'm good my heart is pounding right
now
hey you are you are in safe hands and by
safe hands they're definitely not mine
but kelly and james are driving so
you're good you're good
so what's up
okay so um i have taken a team of people
to romania in september hey real quick
real quick real quick morgan talk
directly into your phone there
okay is that better oh a thousand times
better great
okay um so we're taking a team to
romania in september
to work with ukrainian refugees and i
was just wondering how can i prepare our
team
for the trauma stories that we're doing
here and how can we respond to those
stories as we you know hear them and
interact with those people i love this
question so good and it's applicable
both for people going in to
deal with
war zone refugees and it's also
important for how do you deal with your
middle school kids at home right so
great great question um talk about what
are y'all doing there you all going to
like be giving them food and shelter
what are y'all what work y'all doing
uh that's a great question um our
host there i've been talking with her
about it and she was kind of explaining
like we really don't know obviously what
the status of the war is going to be
when we go and what the needs are going
to be but she gave me an idea of what
they're doing now and they're delivering
supplies they're doing programs for
refugee children they're actually
delivering supplies into ukraine
um they're transporting refugees from
their border to wherever else they need
to go where their family members are so
that's kind of the general idea of what
we might be doing with the time but we
don't really know i love it okay cool
so i'm writing notes down to myself
right here
um and i'm gonna rattle them off at you
okay probably if you don't have
something to write with that's totally
fine you can go back and just listen to
this and we can even send you a clip um
it won't come out for a while but you
may be on the road already so we can
send you something but
um
here's a couple of entry point um things
to keep in your back pocket that would
be great for you to circle up your team
and meet with them how old is your team
going over
um
really all ages i've had some people uh
in high school interested to have people
in their 40s okay all right
so here we go the first thing that's
important is
everybody has to go in with the idea
that we're going to be listeners not
fixers
very little somebody can bring over from
you know dallas texas to ukraine in the
in like you know what y'all should be
doing this
what you could really be
be providing them is a listening ear and
them getting very quickly
a group of people paid their own money
or a group of other people provided the
means for someone to travel over just to
sit with me
they crossed oceans just to be with me
during my darkest hour
and there's it's incredibly healing and
so i would put big number one
listen more talk less
right listen more talk less
um the second thing is i would start a
practice right now so as people are
deciding if they want to go they want to
be a part of this
part of them signing up and saying yes
they put their deposit in or whatever
i want you to have some sort of
journaling apparatus some sort of
journal for them that you're going to
hand them and say you start today and
here's why that's important they're
going to have to have some sort of
processing mechanism and i want them to
practice that a couple of weeks before
they head over there and this is going
to be where you as the supervisor or you
and like a group of team leaders are
gonna really step into this gap here but
i want them to write at the end of every
day and i want you and your team to
spend an extra hour or two before you
all go to bed reading and responding to
these things
okay okay
something about being heard in the midst
of chaos is a gift to the human physique
like physical system it just it lets you
drop your shoulders somebody hear what
i'm seeing right and
you will also begin to see if one or two
of your team members
if they're starting to rattle at the
seams right they're starting to kind of
untether a little bit and that's a great
way people will write things that they
won't say and it's easy when you're
doing this kind of work to
um
you know rally a circle and be like all
right how's everybody well the folks who
are really struggling probably aren't
gonna say anything
and so when you're writing it down they
will um another thing here um
stay off stay off stay off the news
be with be present where you're at and
here's another hard one along that same
line
if at all possible limit the number of
domestic them texting especially them
facetiming back home
y'all go over there be fully there one
of the this is a hypothesis of mine that
i'm still working through and i don't
even know how i would
sit down with a research group to figure
this out but
i've seen we've seen the rise in ptsd
we've seen the rise in just general
anxiety across the world and
i go back to
us our brains are not designed to live
stream war right we're designed to our
brains are designed to respond to
threats in our immediate ecosystem and
when i look at the rise of ptsd among
soldiers i have to wonder if one of the
great gifts is when they're deployed
they can still go watch their kids
little league game because their spouses
can facetime it right or they can see
their spouses and facetime if they don't
have to they can digitally attend
birthday parties
but it also is asking the brain to do
something it's never it's not designed
to do which is to
go out on mission during the day and
then be a dad in my living room 17 000
miles away at night and i'm wondering if
the toggle back and forth is
taxing on their mind i'm not saying
if i'm a soldier and i'm deployed you're
doing right i'm gonna facetime every day
i'm not gonna miss those moments but i
have to wonder if there's some sort of
physiological consequence downstream and
similar here i want that team if they
sign up to go
this is not to facebook stuff and to
send instagram posts it's just to be
present to help hurting people so let's
like we may have a once a week we may
all get together and do facetime back
home but i want everybody present okay
um and then here's the last thing i
would tell you
um every single person on this trip will
come back different
they're gonna change
and
often we really struggle and fight
change as it's happening to us
you can't sit with ukrainian refugees
and not experience
not have that secondary traumatic stress
not have some of that
that
hatred and ugliness and evil and pain
and hurt rub off on you and it hopefully
they can bring those lessons back
but trying to fight that change is gonna
be hard so
you as the leader will be having
conversations about okay what does this
look like moving forward how are you
going to be different what change in the
world are you going to be a part of now
that you've experienced this and so what
we're doing is we're taking that grief
and we're quickly toggling it too making
meaning here right what what changes in
the world are you going to be a part of
as a result of this not
that was a cool experience and we got to
some cool ig posts out of it and i'm
going to go on a college resume or i'm
going to do a talk on it at my local
church no that's not why we're doing
this we're actually going to sit with
hurting people does that make sense yeah
absolutely awesome those are just a few
a few tips um the big one is
my
i think i've talked about on the show
whenever i would go to a scene um a
crisis scene and it was a gruesome
crisis scenes that were just a mess or
really really heavy ones
um whereas you know somebody had been
murdered and the families rallied up in
a circle and
my supervisor would always call and
check in with me and he would say what'd
you see
what's your body doing what'd you feel
what's next and he would just go through
these questions but i always remember
this 2 a.m 3 a.m he's calling checking
in so um i always appreciated that human
connection and
come to find out it's neurologically and
physiologically the right thing to do
also to reconnect each other other
people so make sure you all check in
with each other but thank you thank you
for going to love hurting people that's
really a gift
what what what inspired you to do this
um so in
2018 my sister and i actually went to
jordan to work with syrian refugees
and um
when this opportunity came along i just
knew that that was something that
i felt like god had
kind of created that passion for me to
just go help those people in need
so the things i just rattled off here
would that have applied to your
experience in in syria
oh absolutely yeah like i said
uh then when it comes back different i
was like uh yep
very cool well thank you for your heart
and thank you for being willing to go
love and just sit with people
and usually i like people to enter into
a space with a mission like i'm going to
get people out of this burning building
i'm not going to go hang around in the
building while it burns
i
i i like them too if you're going to
enter into a crisis situation have an
objective but i kind of like your heart
here
we don't know what we're doing
but we're going to go sit with hurting
people and if they ask us to make eggs
then we're going to make eggs and if
they ask us to sweep the floor we're
going to sweep the floor and ask us just
to hold them and hear their stories
write their stories down tell their
stories on our return trips that's what
we're gonna do
that's a beautiful heart thank you so
much we'll be right back
have you ever thought about how a lot of
us would drop anything to help somebody
else but we often don't give ourselves
the same level of care we spend time
energy money on everyone else but when
it comes to making time for vacation for
exercise for talking with a mentor for
sleep even going to therapy
we don't do it and we don't even realize
they won't even think about it
you are worth it
this month betterhelp online therapy
wants to remind you that you are
important
that you are worth being well and
therapy is a super important way you can
show up for yourself
better help is online therapy that
offers video phone even live chat
sessions with your therapist you don't
even have to see anyone on a camera if
you don't want to it's more affordable
than in-person therapy and you can be
matched with a therapist in under 48
hours today dr john daloni show
listeners get 10 percent off their first
month so decide to invest in yourself
you are worth it and go to
to get betterhelp.com off that's
betterhelp.com
delony
all right we are back let's go to brian
in evanston wyoming what's up ryan
how's it going we are rocking on brother
what are you up to
oh i'm just driving along here trucking
excellent man so what's up dude
well i just had a question uh how do i
get over my uh hate and uh just contempt
for my ex-wife
yeah we got two kids together i wanna
i would like to
uh be at least friendly with her but i
mean we split up we split up like over
10 years ago and she's still basically
making my life
insane how did she how's she making your
life it's against me
she's turning the kids against me she's
constantly trying to drive a wedge
between me and my current wife
and and it's just uh it's just really
it's not uh it's putting a negative
impact on my entire life
she's manipulative and vindictive i mean
she gets mad over
over my wife signing a permission slip
for one of the kids
it seems insane to me yeah
um
how'd your marriage end man
oh it ended bitterly bad she cheated on
me uh
you know and then she cheated on me
twice as with two guys as far as i know
and then uh i found out about the first
guy along like after we had already
split up
and she you know i found out about this
other guy
and and i you know that i mean it just
devastated me because we stayed married
another like three years after
after that that guy and and she i mean
she was able to look me in the eye and
lie to me for years
and then you know it's kind of a
bittersweet thing because
it was horrible but we got our second
daughter kayla out of it right and i you
know i it's just
you know it's it's to this day i mean i
it feels like i didn't get any closure
because she won't give manny yeah you
know she she just wants me to die alone
and and
uh miserable yeah
and she's doing her best to make it
happen
why can i ask you a couple hard
questions
do it
why do you give her this much power
like i don't know i i get the like yeah
she's she's
raising hell with the kids that's hard
that just is
we can talk about how to deal with the
kid's stuff that's hard man
but you are continuing to allow her to
you're choosing misery for some reason
and i don't fully get why tell me why i
don't understand i don't get it either
i i would love i want to be happy you
know i i don't
i mean like like
it's left this whole thing has left me
with just crippling self-esteem issues i
can't i can't even be fully open with my
wife that's right and she can she she
can compliment me and i won't even i
won't believe it i don't believe it i
believe she's lying yeah to my face
and but here's the thing here's the
thing i'm gonna give your power back
okay
i want to change your language to i
can't to i choose not to
and there's a reason why you choose to
not trust your new wife because you went
all in on somebody and they burn you to
the ground
right yeah i've been with my wife for 10
years it doesn't matter
it doesn't matter you're still hanging
on to the first one
and more importantly you're not hanging
on to her as much as you're hanging on
to what's wrong with me
and until you can quote-unquote figure
out what's wrong with brian
the truck driver who just wants to be a
good dad and just have a little bit less
sucky life
until you make peace with brian
your brain's going to continue to try to
solve for enemies that don't exist
you were giving a woman a decade ago who
hurt you
access to your present day life
and
why would i want to do that it's not a
matter of want it's a protective measure
until you get back in the driver's seat
of the truck you're moving down the road
in your brain will drive for you
until you sit down and own
oh this happened
and i'm not screwed up something was
wrong with her or maybe i wasn't the
husband i could have been
it was both and often it's both and
and now i get to choose what tomorrow
looks like and you haven't made that
step yet because you haven't grieved it
you haven't just sat there and sat in it
you've had to make peace with the fact
that she's gonna be a part of your life
because you all created kids together
which by the way is also hard because
something good did come from her
right
and you have to own that she's not all
evil she's mostly evil but man she
created two beautiful little kids with
me
and so it's a hodgepodge of emotions
what i don't think you've dealt with
that a lot of people deal with when
they're working through infidelity
is you lost trust in brian
you don't think you're good enough you
don't think you look good enough you
don't think you're smart enough or i'm
just this piece of crap truck driver
probably could lose 40 pounds and fill
in the blank and you've created a whole
story about brian that's not true
and then you go through your life
looking for ways the world can back up
the story the narrative you've created
about yourself and the world's happy to
do that
if you just made more money if you just
look better if you just didn't do this
and your wife your ex-wife's happy to
throw some gas on that fire
yes she is you know what i mean
yeah
you have to make peace with brian
you have to begin to trust brian and
when you trust brian then you can trust
other people
because your brain is not even beginning
to do that
number one you gotta choose
nope let me back up number one you gotta
own reality and you haven't done that
your wife cheated on you period your
wife hurt you bad and she lied to your
face people are capable not all of them
but some people are capable of
incredible
dishonesty and and um
uh incredible disloyalty and it happened
to you you got hurt
you got to own reality and you probably
have to own some crap that you did along
the way right is that fair you weren't
perfect as a husband
maybe you were shoot maybe you were i
mean nobody's perfect i
but i mean you know i didn't cheat on
her i didn't hit her
i've support i've raised our fam we
raised our family we i supported the
family i don't know
what else i could have done different
maybe i'm emotionally unavailable i get
that from my wife all the time sure all
right uh so
that's a problem i'll give you that
there you go so and again i'll give you
emotional
unavailability is a protective measure
because your body remembers hey we were
emotionally available once and it got us
killed so let's put that away let's put
that away right
the sucky part about where you are is
the only way forward
is choosing
to possibly get hurt again that's the
only way
you got to choose to put myself out
there again correct
and right now you share a bed with a
woman who loves you and you're
completely and totally alone and you
know that and especially your body knows
that
and you're around two kids that you
absolutely adore and love and would do
anything for and they kind of look like
your wife and your body knows it and it
says danger danger danger and what you
have to choose is hey i'm gonna start
trusting brian
and i can give you a couple of quick
tips and tricks on how to do that you're
probably not gonna do them but i'll
write them out for you okay the second
thing you're gonna have to do is make a
daily choice for about four months
that my ex-wife does not get a vote in
my life
period
and when i run up against
bonkers things
like you like she's a rattlesnake and
you keep putting your hand in the bag
getting surprised that she that she
bites you
that's just the way she is and so i'm
not trying to figure out a rattlesnake
it just is i'm just gonna put my hand in
the back
and so
my wife the step parent of my two
children sometimes have to sign a
permission slip and so
i know that she's gonna send weird text
and throw a hissy fit because that's
what she does
i'm not gonna allow that to ruin my day
i'm not giving her access to my day
and if she wants to throw a super fit
and cause i'll cut
that's fantastic i'm just gonna call the
lawyer and we'll get an amendment done
i'm just not gonna i'm not gonna fight
you
and there's something incredibly
empowering about looking at somebody
going i i'm not i'm not gonna fight you
hear what i'm saying it's just a totally
different way of looking at the world
but first before you do any of that is
you gotta look at brian and say
yep we missed it
she was sleeping with a friend of mine
she was cheating on me with another guy
and for three years i knew something was
off and i didn't go with my gut and i
stuck it out and it still ended up in
ash and then find out
all right you gotta make peace with that
so that you can look at your new wife
and say for 10 years we've been married
and i've loved you but i didn't know
what that even meant
and i'm going to go all in and so i'm
going to have to practice being
vulnerable again because last time it
got me killed and the only way that you
and i can have a great incredible
recklessly lovely merit lovely marriage
moving forward is if i
risk again
and dude it's so freaking worth it man
it's so worth it brian
yeah that's tough to do it's a dude i
can't i can think of no tougher thing
right i can't think of a tougher thing
i can't
either
but if nothing else your little ones
deserve that man
because they here's the deal they feel
that gap and that tension
so let's talk about your kids real quick
you're playing a 15 or 20 year game with
him right now okay
and it's not going to um
this is an mma match and you are going
to
do a lot of blocking and a lot of
pushing up against the fence
and a lot of foot stomps and a lot of
leg kicks you're not trying to knock
anybody out here you are just
slowly playing a long game here because
your goal is round four and five
okay and you're up against a superior
opponent in the short term which is a
wife who can throw grenades at you that
can say things like oh your daddy
doesn't love you you know what he did
and you can't do anything about that
nonsense
what you can do is continue to show up
and continue to show up and continue to
write your kids little notes
with their from their truck driver dad
to continue to do what you can to be at
the at their events to continue to hold
their face and look them in the eye and
say this house doesn't work without you
and i'm so glad you're my child say that
every day for two months and watch what
happens
they'll roll their eyes at you they'll
be like
and their physiology will change
ask them if you can read them uh
bedtime stories or even better yet make
them up together
and incorporate that right so you can
play long games and what will slowly
happen is the kids are brilliant they
will slowly start to put together oh
she's crazy
because that doesn't make sense
and then one day when they're 17 18 25
33 they'll say hey whoa
you weren't the devil were you and
you'll say no and i loved you every step
of the way that's the game you're
playing right now okay
and that does not give you anything it's
a terrible game it's a it's it's it's
the worst game
it's the worst and i'm s i i'm
heartbroken just guide a guy i'm
heartbroken that your wife your ex is
doing this to you
but i'm not gonna give her one more
moment of rent free space in my head in
my heart period
especially when not one thing she's
doing is surprising me
yeah
like the same same crap same stuff all
the time yeah it's like every time you
walked in to see me i just hit you in
the mouth
like the 48th time you'd be like quit
hitting me and i'd say i hit you every
time quit walking up this close you know
what i mean at one point at some point
we're both at fault
and so i'm just gonna make that choice
i promise you brian
with everything i got
two guys sitting at a bar
over cheap beers and chips in case i'm
talking to you right now i promise you
your way forward
with telling your new wife
of a decade
i'm gonna try something different
and i'm gonna need you to help me and
we're gonna come up with a new language
on when i start
withdrawing
um i'm gonna start saying out loud um
the story i'm telling myself is i'm not
really looking good and you're just
saying that and give her an opportunity
to say nope you do you look good
like you know what screw it can i tell
you brian this weekend
i was with my wife and i was wearing a
shirt
and i like a
t-shirt
and i said hey we were out somewhere and
i looked at her and said hey
i don't feel like um this is a good
shirt for me to be wearing like it just
feels bad on me
and she said you look good
and my first thought was no i don't and
then my second thought was i trust you
i'm still practicing this and i haven't
had near the hurt you've had okay so i
want you to know you're not crazy we're
all figuring this out it's how are you
going to risk that relationship because
my wife could have said yeah never wear
that shirt again you look terrible she
could have said that and then i just
wouldn't worn the shirt anymore right
develop that language with her a couple
of things for you
this is going to sound so cheesy man but
when you're out over the road are you
over the road you go home every day
i get home every day okay
then before you get out of the car i
want you to go to walmart and get
something for six bucks and it's gonna
be a small little black
or red or green little notebook that's
leather bound and i want you to put it
in your truck
and write a few things about the day
down into them
but a couple of these things are i'm
grateful for
and i am a good dad and i'm about to go
in and be a great husband and then once
you get your truck and go inside your
house but i want you to start practicing
writing this stuff down you got to get
out of your head and out of your body
and let your body begin to heal
okay and there's gonna be ups and downs
and sideways and forwards
the goal here is human connection human
touch forgiving brian
and dude you gotta go risk you gotta go
risk and i hate that for you man but you
got to so one way it's the only way
forward
okay do you love this new lady you're
with
yeah
a lot is she cheating on you way better
than the old one
like
like she's a set of tires that's
fantastic better than the old ones
um now she did she'd be gone before she
told me
hey it's probably not going to happen
man
i think this lady loves you
and i know she does reassure me quite a
bit there you go
and so um
you may not believe brian and you're
gonna have to practice believing brian
and learning to trust brian again
um you put that guy in a box for a long
time
start practicing trusting her
and say i believe you and i'm going to
drop my shoulders and exhale i'm going
to choose to believe you
and maybe you tell her
you can hurt me because i'm going all in
on you again and i should have done this
10 years ago and i'm sorry and i've been
protecting myself from more hurt and
more hurt and in the process i built
walls that keep me from you so i'm going
all in and look at her and say
please don't hurt me
i'm going all in on you
please be there with me ride or die till
the end
i'm all in we'll be right back
it seems so easy but most of us way
undervalue real genuine relationships
our friendships our marriages we don't
know what we're doing and instead of
diving into the mess we accept
shallowness and distraction and we
wallpaper over our loneliness so let me
say this boldly you cannot be well alone
you've got to get connected to real life
people and have deep powerful
relationships i'm talking about
relationships where you can be honest
where you can open up where you can
share hard things and you each know that
you'll still show up for each other and
in my new book own your past change your
future we'll walk through a not so
complicated approach to relationships
mental health and wellness and getting
connected is a key part of that that's
why you'll learn shallowness and
loneliness are so dangerous and more
importantly you'll learn how to create
meaningful relationships in your life
moving forward there is no good app to
help adults find friendships but this
book can help go to johndaloney.com to
take the next step towards wellness
that's own your past change your future
at johndaloni.com
all right we are back i gave um brian
during the break there i gave brian
a copy of on your past change your
future if you are wrestling with
i am stuck i cannot make this next step
i don't know how to let the abuse go the
racism go the um exit cheated on me i
can't
i can't
i can't i struggle with the sort of
eating and i don't know what's next i
struggle with depression i don't know
how to get from there to here
from here to what does joey even look
like
if that's you this book's for you okay
check it out on your past change the
future it's in stores it's all over the
place now um go check it out
uh the reviews are i mean it's helping
folks go pick it up all right hey
james uh gave me this article here as
youth mental
illness soars
u.s task force recommends screening
children as young as eight for anxiety
nearly half of young adults reported
feeling anxious or depressed and before
covid
the most recent comprehensive survey
found that eight percent of children had
a current anxiety disorder
and it suggests that it is infinitely
more up to 48 of young adults um
one and two
i've talked about this before on the
show um
here's
here's the deal
i would love for there to be
wired into the curriculum at elementary
schools and middle schools and high
schools
ways that teachers could identify
and
partner with and support and love and
care about kids struggling from
debilitating anxiety
i'm all for figuring out a way to quote
unquote screen kids check them out is
there ways we can look at this
my head instantly goes to when we just
have to do the lice checks and they just
put us in a line in a hallway and that
that was if dude i felt so good it was
the best they had that that uh popsicle
stick and they were just running through
your hair so great but they were looking
for
uh lice
and i think about that like okay cool
often school systems are well-meaning
and but they're can be really blunt
and obtuse when they're trying to
implement some of these things
like testing whatever that's another
conversation
so i'd say like a line out of a hallway
like all right we're doing the anxiety
screening are you sad are you
hey i hope we don't do that number two
here's the problem i have with the
mandatory anxiety screening for kids as
young as eight
what are you gonna do with it
what are you gonna do with that data
you're gonna are you gonna
label a kid and put him in at a
different class put him in a different
track
run him through different whatever
are you gonna make her
go get a bunch of medications or make
her have to do a bunch of psychometric
testing that's really expensive their
family can't afford like what are you
going to do with this data
so if as a parent
a i want to be really careful about
who's tagging my kid with what
diagnostic who's tagging my kid with
what label and more importantly what are
we doing about it because i contend that
our kids aren't quote unquote more
anxious because something's wrong with
them
our kids are quote unquote more anxious
because the world around them the adults
that inhabit their universe have lost
their freaking minds
the adults are acting like children
they're screaming they're yelling
they're running they're live streaming a
war in the living room
they're telling your kids well your
teacher wants you dead the doctor
doesn't know what he's talking about
church is stupid we ain't doing that
anymore
on and on and on and we have melted
these young kids worlds
around them
and their beautiful little brains are
hollering at them hey we're not okay
we're not okay we're not okay we're not
okay
and so dude if a u.s task force
recommends screening kids as young as
eight for anxiety
and when they find out critical masses
of students
have anxiety they're going to start
implementing
recess
and laughter and human connection enjoy
and less drill and kill
response for school testing and
places where kids can rest
because they're having to be at school
at five o'clock in the morning or
whatever like and you heard me run my
mouth about this on this very show
my kids and their silent lunches because
they're too loud
is that what we're gonna do are we gonna
start are we just gonna dope up the kids
or are we going to tell the kids you're
broken or dysfunctional we're going to
make you do something different are we
going to teach them classes about how to
manage stress
how to speak up how to identify it in
their bodies because if we're doing that
i am all in
but if it's just another way to blame a
kid for their brain trying to tell the
adults in their world help me please
please be an adult
stop screaming in the house stop yelling
stop being so indebted that you can't
breathe because if you can't breathe i
can't breathe mom and dad will you all
fix your marriage
brother and sister we all
we're gonna do that man i'm all in
if we're not
what are we doing what are we doing
how'd you wrap up today's show sorry i'm
just gonna end on a bum note here but
we'll loop it back cause james comes
through the clutch
it's a
call back to the first call
with the mom who wanted to know
should i be searching my kid's room
the police wrote a song about this very
situation
it's called every breath you take and it
goes like this
every breath you take every move you
make every bond you break every step you
take i'll be watching you
every single day every word you say
every game you play every night you stay
i'll be watching you
now this could be a really creepy
stalker song i'm not i'm gonna say this
is a song of a concerned parent written
to their teenage children
oh can't you see you belong to me and my
poor heart aches with every step you
take
every smile you fake every claim you
stake
i'll be watching you
and i'm watching you too america we'll
see you soon
coming up on the next episode i'd like
to say
john and james which should be a new
hashtag is that how those work he's got
two guitarists he's got a fender player
and
a gibson player
and together they created magic so like
a guy that can really play and then a
guy that just plays power chords exactly
i see what you did there that hurt my
feelings i teach at one of the best
schools ever and my joy and my passion
for teaching art is just waning
where are you finding joy in other
places in your life i don't
[Music]